На зустрічі зі студентами український прем’єр Денис Шмигаль заявив, що через демографічну ситуацію
держава за 15 років не матиме ресурсів для виплати пенсій.
Тобто ми не зможемо платити пенсії майбутнім пенсіонерам через років 15.
Слова урядовця пожвавили дискусію щодо пенсійної реформи і поставили питання:
а чи має Україна 15 років, щоб змінити ситуацію?
Ви знаєте, я взагалі за накопичувальну систему, щоб я наприклад, на пенсії могла не думати,
як оплатити комунальні послуги і як придбати шматок хліба.
Одна надія на дітей. Тому що ми працювали в радянські часи, не думаючи про себе, а все - щоби державі було добре.
Не відкладаю взагалі, думаю про еміграцію насправді. Тому що я не бачу логіки залишатись тут, поки все нестабільно так.
Мінімальна пенсія, яка мала б бути? В Україні? Ну тисяч 20 хоча би.
Та не буде в нас пенсії, про що ви говорите, не буде в нас пенсії.
В Україні вже нині більше пенсіонерів, ніж тих, хто їх утримує.
За даними Мінпраці, пенсіонерів на 2% більше, ніж офіційно працевлаштованих українців, які сплачують соціальні внески.
За три десятиліття незалежності пенсійна система так і залишилась однорівневою солідарною:
скільки грошей перерахували, стільки й отримали для виплат.
Роками фінансування Пенсійного фонду є дефіцитним. Цьогоріч - на  170 мільярдів гривень.
Наступного року "діра" перевищить 200 мільярдів.
Водночас із 1 січня 2021-го підвищать мінімальну пенсію: як повідомила міністерка праці й соцполітики Марина Лазебна,
65-річний пенсіонер із повним стажем отримуватиме мінімум 2400 гривень на місяць.
Тобто на 300 гривень більше, ніж тепер. Підвищення обіцяють й іншим категоріям. Робитимуть це за рахунок податків.
Однією з найбільших проблем українського ринку праці, яка тисне на пенсійну систему,
експерти одноголосно називають тіньову зайнятість. За даними уряду, торік "тінь" сягала 21-го відсотка.
У Федерації роботодавців статистику вважають заниженою, а частку тіньової економіки оцінюють у понад 45%.
Причина "тінізації" - велике навантаження через фонд оплати праці:
36-40 процентів відрахувань із зарплати лягають на плечі роботодавців.
Крім того, торік понад 3 мільйони 200 тисяч українців працювали за кордоном. Це приблизні підрахунки.
Скільки ж насправді заробітчан - достеменно не відомо. Частина людей працює нелегально,
а це означає, що вони не зможуть зарахувати цей трудовий стаж в Україні.
Не сплачують внески до пенсійного фонду й безробітні - цьогоріч їхня кількість зросте до 9 з половиною відсотків.
Найбільше тих, хто втратив роботу, серед людей віком від 45 років і з вищою освітою.
Тих, про кого згадував прем’єр Шмигаль, за 15 років муситимуть утримувати народжені у 90-тих і на початку 2000х.
Тобто покоління "демографічної ями". Тоді саме спостерігалося різке скорочення народжуваності.
Зазвичай подібні спади трапляються в періоди воєн, катастроф або економічних криз.
До речі, за словами директорки інституту демографії Елли Лібанової, Україна досі не вибралася з "ями" 2000-х:
на одну людину народжується одна ціла шість десятих дитини.
Якщо ситуація не зміниться, у наступні 30 років кількість працездатного населення в Україні скоротиться на третину, прогнозує МВФ.
Тобто годувати сьогоднішніх 40-річних із солідарною системою дійсно буде нікому.
Урядовці, зокрема й прем’єр Шмигаль, бачать вихід у запровадженні накопичувальної системи пенсійних внесків.
Загалом накопичувальна система працює в Україні ще з 2003 року і є добровільною. Однак масовою вона так і не стала.
Передусім, кажуть експерти, через низький рівень доходів і низький рівень довіри до фінансових інституцій,
а також через відсутність розвинутого фондового ринку.
Ідею запровадити обов’язкові накопичувальні внески передбачала ще концепція пенсійної реформи, ухвалена понад 15 років тому.
Останніми роками до Верховної Ради надійшли кілька законопроєктів щодо обов’язкового накопичувального рівня.
Вони передбачають створення індивідуальних накопичувальних рахунків,
на які робітник і працедавець відраховуватимуть пенсійні гроші.
Адмініструватиме ці гроші спеціально створене пенсійне казначейство.
Утім, досвід інших країн колишнього СРСР, які намагалися запровадити цей - другий рівень - пенсійної системи,
свідчить, що прибутковість подібних інвестицій рідко перекриває інфляцію, кажуть експерти.
До того ж, економічна нестабільність і ризики фінансової системи можуть ці заощадження просто спалити.
Експерти вказують на негативний досвід українців зі знеціненням або втратою банківських вкладів.
І додають, що за чинного рівня корупції та низьких доходів, багато українців
сприйматимуть урядову ініціативу як додатковий обтяжливий податок.
Експерти вважають, що вирішенням проблеми може стати лише комплексна пенсійна реформа,
відмова від популізму і детінізація економіки. Саме цього, власне, й вимагає від України МВФ.